recently
um a couple of researchers have found a
a big hack in Tetra which is a system
for radio
um that is used all over the world
um for security critical operations
police forces military apparatus but
also critical infrastructure Like Trains
dams electricity Nets you know important
stuff so this should be like encrypted
and really heavily secure exactly you
want it to be secure you want people not
to know what the communication is you
don't want criminals for example knowing
what the police are saying to each other
and you don't want people to be able to
insert messages you don't want people to
send a message saying open the
floodgates
Tetra is a proprietary standard
supported by a European Institute called
Etsy
a standards Institute and I think it's a
strange choice to have a proprietary
standard and I think I can explain to
you why this is also a point that the
people
um that found the vulnerabilities are
are very strongly making themselves as
well the well-known algorithms like AES
or all the big ones we all know how they
work right the schematics are available
online someone can implement it and then
you can check whether the implementation
follows the design and everyone around
the world can have a look at the design
and see if there's any security flaws
and the answer isn't always going to be
no typically people will eventually find
some weaknesses and sometimes they will
find big flaws and if this is the case
we can update the standard we can make
the changes appropriately and criminals
have a short time window in which they
can potentially exploit it but it won't
be the case that there's a massive gap
for for decades that no one seems to
know about and that's exactly what
happened in in this case Tetra is used
for networks that are built out of radio
stations so you don't want to rely on
the internet but you want to have your
own radio stations and they're
communicating with each other
potentially relaying messages as well
and this is of course very useful for
the applications that we just talked
about right you don't want the police to
suddenly be unable to communicate to
each other or to the station when the
internet goes down or when there's an
emergency and the broad you know the
bandwidth is is sucked up by people
sending messages you want your own
separate system similarly for the
critical infrastructures I just talked
about you don't want to rely on internet
connectivity you want to have your own
system and as we discussed we want this
to be secure
now this is exactly what it is it's a
system
proprietary and in order to keep the
algorithm a secret
manufacturers had to sign a
non-disclosure agreement before they got
the specifications they then had to
implement the algorithm either on
Hardware or on software but then make
sure that it's not possible to reverse
engineer it
now I say it's not possible of course
it's possible right
um all you can really ask is that they
make it very difficult to reverse
Engineers the three guys involved are
Carlo Mayes voterbox and yours vetsels
where are they from anywhere uh they
might be from the same country as we but
that's a total coincidence
um but at least I can pronounce their
names
um so they
spent quite a bit of time and effort
reverse engineering
the protocols and the the implementation
thereof
because of course there's multiple
manufacturers all it really takes is one
manufacturer
to not quite secure the system as well
as they should have in terms of being
able to reverse engineer it so they were
able to find a machine with an
implementation that had some weaknesses
that were exposing bits and Bulbs of the
internal workings
and they were able to exploit that to to
find out what the code is what the
algorithms are
and then step two they analyzed it and
what I found was not very good they
found a whole list of weaknesses and
vulnerabilities several of which were
bad but two of which were really really
bad so I'm going to be talking about the
two that are really really bad
um so the first one is
a vulnerability that exists across all
implementations of tetra
later on we're going to talk be talking
about one specific implementation but
this one is true for all of them which
is why I would say this is the worst one
um so all cryptographic Primitives used
in ETC are proprietary and they're all
Stream ciphers So a stream Cipher is one
of two major types of symmetric
encryption one is the block Cipher
the analogy is
um you're chopping a file up into bits
and pieces and then scrambling them
together and your secret key tells you
how you scramble it but also how you
unscramble it a scream Cipher is
different and a key is used to generate
a long stream of bits and this stream of
bits can then be used as a so-called
one-time pad so how does that work
well let's start with a naive stream
Cipher
so we have some key and we're using this
key as input to some magic box and then
the magic box outputs a stream of bits
let's call them b0 B1
Etc then we have a message our message
of course is digital so this is also a
sequence of bits let's call them m0 M1
Etc what we can then do is we can take
the bitwise exclusive or and what that
does is it combines the bits in a in a
reversible way such that we get a secret
message this is our ciphertext and so
the ciphertext will then be
c0
C1
Etc
where the bit CI is simply determined by
taking the ith bit from the bit stream
and the if bit of the message
and taking the xor now the xor
is a bitwise operation so if we have
zero
X or zero what it does is it Compares
them and if they are the same the output
will be zero
but if they are different
the output will be 1.
another way to think about it is that
we have a message M and the bits B and
the bits determine whether or not we're
flipping the bit right so if this is our
original message we say we have a 0 x or
zero we're not flipping the bit so we're
keeping zero one so we're zero well we
have a one
we're not flipping it because it's zero
so we remain one all we have zero but
now we accelerate with one which means
we flipped a bit so a zero becomes a one
and a one becomes a zero that's how you
can think about it now obviously if you
xor a message
twice with the same bit string you get
your original message back
and this is of course exactly what we
want so in other words we can get our
message back by taking our ciphertext
and applying the same stream Cipher so
now all we need to do to communicate in
secret with each other is make sure that
we agree on the same
bitstream there's the same key in this
case right because the key is generating
the bitstream
um and we both have the same one so I X
over it with the bitstream you take that
result xor it as well and now we agree
on the same message and we've
communicated to each other in secret
can you see potentially a problem here
the case the the problem surely the key
how you generate that thing if if you
don't get that key right so
no it's not how you generate the key
it's actually how you use the key okay
because let's say that I'm running the
same protocol tomorrow what will the bit
stream be the same it will be exactly
the same and this is of course a massive
problem because I can take the two
Cipher texts and xor them with each
other and the bit streams will cancel
out and the result will be the xor of
the two messages in other words if I
have two Cipher texts with the same bit
stream we get let's say m i
xor
bi that's m is our first message
and then we accelerate with the other
ciphertext let's call it m Prime I
sore
bi well xor you can move the things
around just like with a plus so we can
move these two together and they will
cancel out so the result will be
MI xor
M Prime I
which means that if I know something
about M Prime I I know something about
Mi right so I can use this as a this is
called a decryption Oracle and so if I
can manipulate the values of M Prime I
can learn the values of M and this is a
big problem this is one of the worst
things that can happen so
instead of using a single input we need
to use two inputs the other input being
a so-called initialization Vector this
is not a secret unlike the key but it's
a fixed value that changes every time
you use it so both parties will know if
we're using the stream Cipher in this
context this will be the IV and this is
immutable so that means that I cannot
manipulate the IV to be the same
tomorrow as it will be today so we're
guaranteed to end up with a different
bit string
now I think you can see where I'm going
with this
the implementation of tetra doesn't do
this correctly what it uses for the
initialization Vector is some
information that can be found in the
data frames that are used in the
protocol
so in particular it will be a sequence
number relating to the frame as well as
the current time and some other
information that's not so relevant now
what the attacker can do
to trick the system
is they can reset the
um
sequence number because the sequence
number increments every time people
communicate so I can just come up with a
sequence number that was used in the
past and the system thinks oh something
must have gone wrong and then resets to
that point something it shouldn't be
doing but it will and that means that
now the same initialization Vector can
be forced by the attacker to be used by
the system which means stream reuse and
this is a total break right it means
that we can pretty much read everything
insert messages do whatever we want and
we didn't use any of the properties of
the proprietary implementations of the
cryptography we just used the way the
crypto was used
so that's the first break the other
break has to do with the actual
implementation of the system the system
uses various implementation of the
cryptography these are
handcrafted crypto which is usually not
a good idea right you want to use the
publicly existing
cryptographic Primitives simply because
they're well tested they've been used
they've been studied and any weaknesses
that are potentially still there
are going to be very difficult to find
um here perhaps not so much so
they have four Primitives that you can
select tea
A2 ta3 and tea A4 now tea
is only allowed to be used by Nations
that were associated with the European
Union
because the standards Institute Etsy is
a European Institute and they simply
restricted exports to only Europeans and
friends effectively
then t-a-a-t-e-a-3
um what had a more liberal definition of
friends so it could be exported more
widely but not to countries that that we
wouldn't consider well that the EU
wouldn't consider to be to be friends so
think of countries like Iran in
particular
um so these countries were forced to use
tea one
there's also dea4 but it's not quite
clear who the intended audience for that
was and it seems to not really be used
so we will ignore tea ea4 for now
um and it was tea one that was
fundamentally broken
um so in part because of export
restrictions
um that were
there in the 90s in the US
there was a limit on how big the keys
could be so the key the tea one uses was
80 bits which is
probably enough right if you use it
properly it should be enough but they
weren't allowed to use all 80 bits so
the protocol actually selects 32 bits
from those 80 bits in in
some way and those 32 bits we can call
it the truncated key those 32 bits are
actually the bits that are used in the
protocol so the protocol is running on a
32-bit key even though the input key is
80 bits but that means it's brute
forcible right so if we can enter the
calculation at the stage of the
truncated key we can just try all 2 to
the power 32 combinations and see which
one it is and so that's that's really
bad then to make matters worse
um the way in which the truncation was
done allowed researchers to even try to
figure out what the original key was
based on the truncated key
so tea one is completely broken and part
of the reason why it's broken was
because of export restrictions that
existed in the time now a mistake like
this could not have survived
scrutiny right anyone looking at this
would immediately say hey this is an
issue this is not a secure protocol and
in fact in some Communications about
the very system people were saying well
it's actually only 32 bits so we're
allowed to export it to Iran that's why
I'm mentioning this example because
that's a country that has these to which
America has these export restrictions
um
so what what did we learn from this
right so the authors have reverse
engineered system so from this we can
learn why it's a bad idea to try to hide
the implementation of a protocol right
these are three good guys that have
reversed engineered it immediately took
action you know warned people
um and waited until for publication
until the system was mostly fixed
have other people found it in the
meantime certainly I would imagine so
um nothing you know negative to say
about these three guys but I'm sure that
any organization with a bunch of Smart
Guys in this domain that really wanted
to do this would have been able to to
reverse engineer it and not necessarily
tell anyone about this so this could be
a criminal organization this could be a
security organization so you're never
going to be able to keep your secret
protocols actually secret
um
so that's one thing we can learn the
other thing we can learn
is that
um the lack of scrutiny allows these
vulnerabilities to exist for much longer
than they should have countries in
organizations
Etc we're all using weak versions of a
protocol for decades and God knows
whether or not there were bad actors
that had already knowledge about certain
techniques to to abuse the system right
we will never know this they why would
they tell us right so fortunately these
three guys have you know taking the
effort to reverse engineer it which I
think is really cool
thing to do
then figured out how the protocols
worked found some weaknesses and I would
really expect
people that are more sort of experts on
this sort of crypto to be able to find
some additional weaknesses and
vulnerabilities in addition to to what
they have already found I did see a
report on this to him and it said
something about a deliberate baked in
back door is that something that was
also there was that one of these
vulnerabilities I mean the fact that we
can even speculate about this being a
possibility is an issue right
um
there have been instances in the past of
this happening it's not clear at the
moment whether it was a deliberate
backdoor
um the the authors do mention a a
suspicious
um s books now we don't really have to
know what an Xbox is but it's a small
part of the cryptographic algorithm and
it's working in a strange way now
whether this is intentional accidental
or you know uh nefarious
we don't know but the point is the fact
that this thing has been there for 25
years without anyone knowing about it is
harmful in and of itself
so this one goes all the way over to
here this one goes over here and so and
so on remember this is going to be an
intuitive process and what we want to do
is move these things around and permute
them exclusive or gate with two inputs A
and B the output of those is called the
sum it's the sum in that column